Let's go next to our caller from the two 67
area code two six seven. What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hi David. My name is William [inaudible].
I wanted to talk to you about immigration.
So you talked about, you talked about how
the right smears, the left by saying the left
supports open borders, right. But I think
both sides just viewed this subject differently.
Okay. So I think the right views of the left
as pro open borders because they are generally
soft on enforcing deportations. Like when
people come here illegally, the left is generally
not as fast to support them to be deported,
if that makes any sense.
So what would be an example of that? Who,
who are you talking about? People who have
done what exactly.
I don't have any specific examples. I just
have a general feeling of like that's based
off of a bunch of lesbian commentators and
people on the left that I've spoken to personally.
That's the general vibe of they don't really
want people to be deported. Like, like for
instance, I've heard on your show how you
support people being deported. They've done
a violent crime but they've already come here
illegally. So I think just coming here is
enough for deportation because they don't
belong here. They were born here. They didn't
haven't done.
So listen, let, let me give you, let me give
you what I think is the predominant view.
There is no doubt that there are immigration
activists who say, if you've come here illegally
but haven't committed any other crime, it
should be treated sort of like a civil infraction.
It should be a ticket or whatever you S you
should not be deported. Okay. I don't think
that's the predominant view. My understanding
of the predominant view on the left is there
is no question that countries are allowed
to have borders and immigration law and enforce
immigration law. The disagreement comes in
that the priority should not be as a solution
to go out and proactively find people who
have committed no other crime other than being
here illegally and deport those people when
there are so many other things that should
be done first. Like for example, um, we should
be looking at, uh, overstayed a visa because,
and we should be looking at technology on
the border and we should be looking at a path
to citizenship for DACA to make sure that
those people who came here through no choice
of their own, there's a lot of priorities.
And then even beyond that, there are other
criminal priorities within the United States
that are higher priorities than just finding
people who are here illegally and deporting
them. So I'm sure you're right, there are
people who don't want undocumented immigrants
to be deported at all. Uh, I don't think that's
the primary view. I think the primary view
is that choosing to make the priority to do
ice raids and just find people who are here
working hard, whatever when it was your faulty
system to begin with, that allowed them to
come here to start with seems like a totally
misguided priority. I think that's really
the issue.
Oh, okay. Well I definitely agree with that.
It shouldn't be a priority and especially
since some people have been deported by accident,
I don't think people should be going through,
you know, list of, of citizens and trying
to get people out.
There's also an issue of civil liberties.
William, there's a civil liberties issue also
where for example, I don't think that if police
pull you over and you have a driver's license
and you were speeding, I don't think it should
be in their purview to ask questions about
or explore your immigration status. That should
not be the job of local police, for example.
Does that mean I think anyone should be allowed
to come to the U S illegally anytime. No,
but from a civil liberties perspective, I
don't believe that that's the job that local
police should be doing. You understand the
distinction?
Yeah, absolutely. And I agree with that as
well. Cool. So everything you're saying I
agree with, so,
all right, good. Well, hopefully we've changed
your view, at least on the predominant view.
I appreciate the call. I've got a lot of people
holding, so I'm going to move on. But uh,
you know, a lot of times I feel like our disagreements
are based on misunderstanding the other person's
position, not actually disagreeing about the
principal. Let's go next to our caller from
the three to three area code color from three
to three. What's your name? Where are you
calling from?
Hey there, David. My name's Josh. I'm calling
from LA. What's going on?
Um, had kind of a strange question for you,
a little bit more like a career based type
question, but, uh, if you'll be so kind, let
me take a running start at this. Um, so I've
been, uh, sort of politically politically
activated back in 2016 when I started watching
people like you and young Turks and Caicos
Lynskey um, kind of never really liked politics,
didn't trust politicians until I heard about
Bernie Sanders. He changed everything for
me. He basically made me politically activated.
Um, I'm a professional cinematographer living
in LA. And, uh, my question for you is, uh,
I'm just, I'm trying in my own way to push
the Overton window to the left. I, I try and
talk to friends and family about important
issues. Anyone I meet really at a party like
Laura does. My wife would say, I've ruined
lots of weddings by, you know, chatting up
people who had political disagreements with
me. Um, but basically my question for you
is like how in my own way in my own sphere,
can I push that window to the left and I'm
not really able or interested in doing what
you do, which is uh, being on camera. Um,
I'm a camera man myself, so I'm looking to
amplify people's voices on the left. I'm just
wondering if you had any tips.
So you want to amplify voices from the left,
but you don't want to be on camera. And I'm
guessing you don't want to be involved in
producing the show either.
Oh no, I want to be involved in producing
it. I just don't have like the wherewithal
to like go on camera and do what you do.
Oh, so we'll listen. I mean there's a lot
of people who do what I do, but they don't,
they lack either the technical skills or the
business skills or the access to the equipment
to do it. So I would say partner up with someone
who does want to be on camera, but lacks the
skills that you have. And then now instead
of it just being one guy or gal who has to
figure this out, now you've got two people.
I mean, one of the things that really, I've
seen a lot of shows fail, not because the
host has bad ideas or is a bad communicator,
but I've seen shows fail because they can't
get the tech side together. They can't get
it together enough to be regularly producing
content, which is what it takes to start building
things up. So I would say partner up with
someone who does want to be on camera. Bring
your skills to the table.
I have, I've tried that. Yeah, I've, I've
contacted, um, other, uh, campaigns. Like
I, I hit up a shot booter and uh, flew to
San Francisco and shot some content for him
pro bono. Um, I'm looking to do more stuff
like that, but, um, these campaigns, of course,
I volunteered for JAG and I volunteered for
Bernie. Those campaigns that never written
me back. I'm sure they get a billion emails
a day. Um, I was just wondering if you knew
of any other local, uh, Progressive's uh,
or maybe not local, but
I, I don't, but again, I'm, I'm saying not,
don't get jumped in with a candidate because
the candidate might win and then their elected
official, are they losing them? They disappear.
Really look at starting an ongoing program
with someone who, who is interested in being
on camera as a host, not as a candidate. You
know what I'm saying?
Yeah. Yeah. I think that's a great idea. Yeah.
Because then it's sort of like that the conversation
continues over. Whoever gets [inaudible].
Exactly right. And this is honestly, this
is one of the problems I see with Bernie in
2016 in 2020 I've seen it with tools, see
Gabbard where channels pop up, where there,
it's just about the candidate only. And then
if the candidate doesn't win, all of that
audience and Goodwill that you've built up
kind of disappears because it was based around
a candidate. So I like the idea of building
a show either around the host or around an
issue rather than a candidate. I think that's
the way to go.
Or even broader, like about an ideology.
Sure. Of course. Progressive ideology. Uh,
okay. I hope that that's somewhat useful.
I appreciate it.
All right, Josh, Josh from LA. Let's take
a quick break. If you're holding, don't hang
up because I will go right back to the phones
after this short break.